There's not a week that goes by that
they don't get an email,
a phone call from a random person who
wants advice on how to enter the
nonprofit sector in the unit to have a
career in the nonprofit sector,
uh,
because they think it's where they can
find the most fulfillment.
And this is really inspiring to see so
many people,
uh,
from young people to mid career
professionals,
even retired professionals wanting to go
into the social impact space because say
they,
uh,
are convinced that this is where they
would find the most fulfillment.
But you know,
the reverse can be true as well because
burnout in the nonprofit sector is a
very real thing.
In fact,
there,
ah,
I once had the conversation with a group
of monastics from,
uh,
the group of teak,
not Han who said that the people who
visit their,
um,
their monastery in France too,
to take some time off on a retreat are
mostly coming from the nonprofit sector
because they become so burnt out.
They become so disillusioned.
They become just so fatigued by the
causes of the nonstop,
uh,
at tvt that is required of them.
But I have also encountered so many
people who,
uh,
I mean they barely make a living and
they're,
the way they make their living exposes
them to the most miserable conditions
and the planet where there's,
there's abuse,
there's a war,
there's hunger,
there's poverty and there's not even a
comfortable place to sleep.
And what is it,
what is it about these people that uh,
that keep,
uh,
what,
what is it that keeps him happy
regardless?
And there are a few things that I
learned.
This is among the people who actually
choose to be in the nonprofit sector.
One is that they have a life outside of
their work.
You know,
they,
they do not associate themselves with
the cause.
They are not the cause.
So they actually have an identity
outside of their work and they treat it
as a job like any other.
The other thing I saw in these people is
that,
uh,
they think when,
when,
you know,
when you're in a,
when you're in a situation where you're
constantly asking people for help,
you're constantly fundraising,
you're constantly asking for support,
uh,
you know,
to sign this petition to donate to this
cause it then you,
you start to feel that you are in a
position of need all the time.
And that's wrong because that can make
you feel really depleted.
What I saw in these people is that they
may see themselves as having something
to offer all the time.
So they don't see themselves as a needy
one in every situation.
They actually see themselves as able to
give something,
give something in return,
and that empowers them in a
conversation.
The other thing I noticed about people
who are working in very,
very,
um,
miserable situations but nevertheless
find so much fulfillment is that they
are,
uh,
they find strength in their group.
They never do it alone and they don't
have what I call the founder's syndrome.
Sometimes when you're too close to the
essay,
the nonprofit that you started,
or the cause that your,
your name,
uh,
stands for,
then it becomes your,
uh,
it becomes your identity and it becomes
too,
too closely,
uh,
entangled with every single thing about
your life.
But no,
the people I learned who,
who maintain a healthy balance or those
who are able to take a step back and
still enjoy things outside of their
work.
Okay.